i'm delighted to welcome so many leaders
here from right across the world
basically you represent not only the
diversity of the world
but also the diversity of democracies
because each of our democracies is
different and unique
but ultimately
democracy in all its forms
comes down to the same thing
it gives people a voice
it gives the ability to change things at
the ballot box
in democracies we even fight for people
to be able to be against us
to be able to speak their mind to change
their mind
to be free to be yourself
so that if you're different from the
majority you are always equal before the
law
it is the accountability to all not only
to those who voted for you and that is
democracy
a system where power is given
and taken away by citizens
and framed by checks and balances
so our debate today will be about
drawing on each other's experience to
help strengthen our democracies
here in europe we have learned that we
must always every single day nurture
and work on improving democracy
because we know how quickly and how
devastatingly
history can change
we know that the opponents of democracy
today
are using new tools and very modern
technologies
to oppress and manipulate through
systematic disinformation
this information is not a party
political issue it is a societal one
we know also that autocracy can even be
born from within democracy
and its poison can take over by misusing
institutions and democratic openness
to gradually shut down opposition curb
freedoms and to finally impose one
autocratic vision of society
we will not let that happen
and this is why the european union and
its member states are the biggest global
donor
in the area of democracy support
we will allocate 1.5 billion euros to
promote human rights and to foster
democracy globally
beyond this our global gateway strategy
will unleash 300 billion euros for
infrastructure investments around the
world
infrastructure
that is based on values on transparency
and on sustainability
to really give an alternative
and we have also put forward measure to
help measures to help protect people
from illegal content online
from hidden political advertising or
disinformation
we want to work with our partners to
ensure
that digital technologies are driven by
the values which our societies are built
on
i think that today's discussion has
shown how colorful democracy is
and how we all use different words and
pictures to describe what it means to us
and to the people we serve
we have seen just how vibrant democracy
is around the world and just how strong
the commitment is to strengthen it
common understanding that democracy can
and must deliver for people we all face
many of the same challenges
how to promote greater participation
how to protect free press from fake news
and disinformation
how to root out corruption and
strengthen the rule of law
we all know and that was very
interesting to hear it in different
voices that democracy is imperfect by
design and imperfect in reality
but there's also a common will to
reinforce democracy
as the fairest way to deliver the
greatest benefits to people around the
world
to create societies that are equal
and allow opportunities to all
so today's session
is not the end of something it is the
beginning
of a new push for democracy